10h30 c'est l'heure du briefing pour les
quelque quarante sept jeunes pilotes
le planning du jour entre 300 et 400 km
à parcourir avec des conditions météo
idéales
cet après midi on a quand même un apport
d'humilité suffisant pour avoir hélas
cumulent ification mais également des
nuages de haute altitude
après avoir étudié le parcours direction
le planeur pour les dernières
vérifications
marius est un habitué maintenant cela
fait cinq ans qu'il a pris son envol
chez moi donc c'est vrai j'ai un petit
peu davantage de connaître le coin
donc j'essaye j'ai essayé de faire le
maximum que je peux pour représenter mon
club
une semaine d'épreuves pour les pilotes
en herbe dans ce monde très masculin
illness fait partie des trois seules
filles de la compétition où j'aime
voulait le milieu de l'aéronautique me
passionne énormément et dans le planeur
ce qui est intéressant c'est de tout
faire sans moteur d'être tout le temps
aller coûte d énergie qui nous entourent
parce qu'on utilise les ascendances pour
remonter et c'est être en perpétuelle
recherche de
2 comment optimiser le vol à partir de
ce qui nous entoure au niveau des
naturel qu'on sait c'est génial tous les
honneurs de la classe club est ouvert
les jeunes pilotes partent les uns après
les autres
arrivé en haut ils doivent attendre que
tout le monde ait décollé ils doivent
voler le plus vite possible ou le plus
loin possible en fonction du type de
circuit et on arrive assez régulièrement
à des vitesses de 120 130
kilomètres/heure 110 km heure de moyenne
sur des vols de 150 200 300 kg sur la
campagne
le départ est lancé
les pilotes s'envole vers leur objectif
un titre de champion de france et
pourquoi pas une sélection pour les
championnats du monde